here's a peek at what guests had to say
after the show okay we're back here on
the internet with questions for the
panel Bradley are cops spying on people
now more than they used to spying on
people cops doing that too yes mostly
because of Technology they can access
your cell phone pretty easily now we've
also seen some really crazy stuff going
on in NYPD was spying on some of the oh
yeah the the mosques and some of the
Muslim groups have their own CIA the New
York police right they do and then we've
got Maryland there's stories in Maryland
of police infiltrating sort of anti-war
movements and you know very sort of
non-threatening protest groups so yeah
there is I mean you know there's always
a danger of harkening back to a
Pollyanna ish time that never existed I
mean Nixon did quite a lot of spying the
police in that era were not nearly as
sort of right it was the technology
because yeah J Edgar Hoover raped Martin
Luther King but they had to put like an
actual reel-to-reel tape machine under
his bed but I would also have really
right didn't the guy down there yeah but
but it but it works both ways though
right I mean we now have I mean it's
hard to overstate how powerful it is
that all of us are carrying a camera in
our pocket now that can not only record
but can instantly stream video and audio
to off-site servers it's also heard when
you turn it off it's not really complete
well there's that problem too yeah is
that real yeah it can take we can turn
it on turn your phone on remotely I got
a picture of my car going through a red
light I got that in the mail yeah yes oh
yes well yeah dirty pool I hate that
they're all over I like doing that I
think if you make it through the red
light your cue should be those have been
used in my divorce cases and she's also
helping in the sense that you now police
officers you can have a camera so you
can monitor your interactions with
civilians which oh yeah huge improvement
all right well I mean yeah I think
generally again this fact that we all
have a camera you can record your
interactions with cops I mean the Arab
Spring we saw you know government have
been cracking down on dissent since the
dawn of time and we actually saw
real-time video and photos of
governments you know killing people who
were protesting I mean that's amazing
it's hot
powerful that is okay is Elizabeth
Warren a serious 2016 contender or is
she too inexperienced on non fiscal
issues no I don't think so but I mean
she's obviously the one that the more
left
Democrats would prefer to the centrist
Clinton presidency anybody here would
endorse that who who if you had a your
choice eyes were who would you be for a
Hillary Clinton or I don't pick
candidates oh look at you because it
will be Mayflower suddenly mr.
politician rub it you don't have a
personal preference no I mean first
we've not seen either than run for it to
just do a choice between Elizabeth
Warren and Hillary Clinton now what is
Elizabeth Warren's foreign policy right
like how do you make even the choice if
you were going to without knowing any of
that so but broadly speaking I think my
job is not to tell people who to vote
for I think people are under estimating
Elizabeth Warren for this reason that
the notion that I've heard is that
Barack Obama is unique because United
college educated white social liberals
and african-american voters which is
very potent in the Democratic primary
whereas Elizabeth Warren can only get
1/2 of that but I think that that's
under estimating the level of discontent
that there is among Democrats period and
the openness that people might have to
someone who is running an unconventional
campaign who is not an overly familiar
face I also think that people have to
kind of narrow view of what
african-american voters think what
they're like who they're going to
gravitate towards I think it's quite
possible they might be willing to you
know embrace a you know a white staunch
progressive yeah I see no reason think
so but and she'll be the populist
candidate for sure measured against
Hillary but you know I think it would be
refreshing for Democrats if they want a
populist candidate to go to someone
who's actually very progressive very
liberal necessarily on all these huge
government takeover issues I mean she's
a big financial services person I would
like to see a progressive from my home
state I see Feingold come back he was a
good last anti-war liberal I want to see
him come back and really rally the base
around those issues they used to be very
important to the left and don't seem to
be any I'd like to see someone even left
he gives a damn about civil liberties I
mean to actually give a voice to
be somebody from the right who gives a
damn about several lives besides Rand
Paul yeah the last week or that was Bob
Barr
what we just have one who's yours what
what do you mean we have Rand Paul oh we
rise yeah you're right
you're right you know Ron Wyden you've
got some yeah why didn't I think it's a
lot of credit on a lot of he's not about
to run for president no he's not running
for me he's just does Arnold
Schwarzenegger actually have any chance
at all in getting the Constitution
change so he can run in 2016 is it is he
drying maybe if he anti-cruise ally
themselves they can really steamroller
Swartz Integra's of Schulenburg 60 what
was even is he thinking about me that's
the apple of movies have tanked right is
that Arnold himself doesn't it yeah yeah
you'd never worked with him what you
person trust you digger if if they are
people in your oh no no I wouldn't I was
gonna sit here in the shower I forgot
but the cat your cast in this movie is
like an all-star cast of the most
intense actors of all time all the
people I think it was like this super
intense guys you Christian Bale Willem
Dafoe Woody Harrelson Forest Whitaker's
in there yep great well you're not
mentioning with Will Ferrell Vince
Vaughn also they're all the real serious
yeah
will the will the Affordable Care Act
failures end Republican infighting or
will it energize the Tea Party even well
Morsi energized the Tea Party as part of
the debt negotiation should Republicans
given a little to sequester cuts well I
think they'd certainly be willing to and
I think that as a rock she wrote a
really great piece on this about how
Democrats you yeah about how Democrats
should give up on tax increases and
focus on the sequester because that's
their main priority now that really
forces liberals to give up their main
priorities by trying to keep the size of
government bigger and I think
Republicans are open to negotiating on
sequester but it would be in exchange
for me to run for off yeah I would also
refrain II will not even say whether it
Elizabeth Warren over Hillary : I won't
do that I'm a journalist but I will say
that while I argued in the article which
I do believe strongly is that one
Democrats in terms of sequesteration
lost on the idea they could get taxes
and return for it but two that the right
deal here should actually expand we have
a very narrow conception of what matters
in the budget immigration reform would
be great for the budget and I would take
immigration reform over all kinds of
budget uh energy taxes did you get
anything into your car back in a way I'm
not that unhappy immigration reform
isn't going through because there's
forty six billion dollars in that bill
for police on the border it's just
another way to keep going this
military-industrial complex the military
police industrial complex now it's the
border police just real calm so I'll be
waiting for some money to people who
want it's 11 million people here who are
harder for police to screw with now so
so I'll be a lot I'll be the only person
on this on this panel I'm sure who says
that the big problem sequester is the
the nature of the military cuts that
you're going to see they're going to get
a lot more severe and I think if you
look at the situation in Benghazi for
example you know Diplomatic Security if
you look at the ability to pre position
assets
you know I definitely agree that there's
a lot of wasteful spending in the
military but I think that the way these
sequester cuts are going to work out is
going to be very very destructive for
make setting sensible priorities so I
think that Republicans are going to need
to make concessions if they want to
preserve a but absolutely something like
Westar the Defense Department will never
prioritize it doesn't have to so that's
why you need something as severe as well
I'm not saying sequester is very I'm not
analogous pannonica I do it but I think
that yet I'm gonna way to do it overall
spending level obviously I think is
something both conservative I think
that's a fair point yeah okay
thank you everybody thank you audience I
appreciate you helping us
Real Time with Bill Maher Friday night
at 10:00 ask bill and his guests who are
questions right after the show
at hbo.com